[Music]
hey everybody here's another episode of
you welcome with me your favorite
Marcela argüello my guests today are
Heidi he's lit who's a great comedian
and has a show coming soon to e called
the funny dance show and Sue shears
Amida who was a movie the weekend
currently streaming and a great podcast
with Nicole Byer called best friends
thank you ladies for being here today
how are you doing what's going on
I mean I'm good I'm good everybody's
good I'm promoting a movie right now
oh yes promoting a movie yeah it's
called again very excited yeah it's a
romantic comedy tone Belle's in it he's
great I love romantic comedies hey Tony
come for the romance leave for dead yeah
yeah that's really all I'm doing right
that's good good for you Congrats
thank you very much what's going on with
you I mean I got the funny dance show
coming out on E that's based off of a
live show that myself and Justin Marino
created at the Comedy Store but also we
shot it like last year yeah but it's not
out yet so just like you know doing a
lot of pool days whole tour sitting
around being like funny how long these
things like nothing so people don't know
that but for us it's just like oh my god
and then you're also like trying to
figure out what's next and what do you
have a schedule work and then all of a
sudden they pick a date and yeah oh well
now I have to reschedule everything yeah
yeah yeah yeah it was cool I was a guest
on this show it was so fun yes it was so
good it was fun I it was I got pulled
aside a lot to be like you're the only
one who wants to be ugly on this show
she really really you really
way that like we wanted yeah it was fun
and it was a fun experience too it was
also like I don't people don't know me
as someone who does characters and like
it's fun for me to do characters but
they do know you as a dancer they do
people die dancer yeah that's true I've
been known to moonwalk across many a
dance floors I mean there was a whole
like production office of like we're
being you have to look at her dance
videos so ladies you're both in
successful relationships
thank you switch congratulations the
fact that I booked you both on the same
show is wild because that never happens
to women comedians who are doing well in
the dating life world I was even
thinking I was like I'm like a couple
other women that are in a relationship
they're not successful in each other
iffy on enough or yeah just sended yeah
so I wanted to talk about navigating a
first of all a successful relationship
while you're I don't know a little bit
literally what I never thought I would
be this girl where someone's like you're
in a successful relationship like it's
like that doesn't that concept doesn't
even make sense to me like I almost be
wild it feels like you know the Everest
commercials where the dude was like get
up off your couch like that's real like
I'm like if I could do it you got a good
man like what are you waiting on girl
like that sorry like it's doesn't and
almost every day I wake up and I'm like
is he tripping like why some but then on
my confidence days I'm like yeah
obviously he made a wise decision right
yes have you had like previous many
successful relationships or is this like
your first oh wow this is both of our
first like real adult relationship oh
wow yeah and it feels really good and
it's been five years it's been a really
long time really when he came into my
life I was in a period I mean I feel
like everyone says I was in a period
where I was like no more boys I was
just like I'm take a break I just like
the idea that you think everyone's
saying no more boys
you had made the decision that you were
like I'm not taking ya yeah and
maybe I guess that changed my mindset
too because I was like instead of being
like is he gonna text me tomorrow like
instead it was waiting to be like I'll
take the scraps that like a little yeah
like the little nubbins of love people
are giving me you know what I don't need
any of that right yeah and when it feels
good I'll feel good and then this guy
came and it was feeling good and yeah
that's right I still going strong yeah
yeah she just believed her hanging I was
not in that place at all like my
boyfriend and I had known each other for
like a few years but like he's always
seen like stable and like a good dude
and I was like yeah those don't really
know see that's not that's totally for
somebody else for sure and then one
night I was like drunk and he's like
Instagram with like some other people
who had worked with it like Korean
barbecue and I like D I'm dim and I was
like why don't you taking me I was just
remember because sometime I wanted to go
to and then I like woke up in the
morning and he was like we don't really
do this all the time but like you and I
could go and I was like oh yeah sure
whatever
yeah and then and then one night I was
like trying to rebound and he invited me
out for some drinks and I was like
it free drinks right right and then we
went out to drinks and it was he was
like super cool and I was like oh my god
oh my god I knew want to talk to me well
yeah yeah you're out the end my vessel I
love it I just love that you said it
like you were drunk but he probably read
it like you should take me to Korean
with you sometime
I mean thought about that I should take
her to Korean boat sometime yeah and he
said that he had always kind of had a
crush on me I like girls like me
wouldn't want to be with a guy like him
so we were both like I'm now writing a
romantic I love
it's great it's so great I love it I'm
jela mm-hmm I'm a poly dude oh
yeah not been there so leading up to
these successful relationships leading
up to the successful relationships how
did you navigate the world of dating
I pretty much dated anyone in everyone
yeah I would go younger
oh very younger very older various races
that's amazing just saying well no
emotionally unavailable was usually a
lot of stuff that I was going but like a
woman of the ball yeah I was just like
let's just give everybody a shot I
didn't mean that I like had sex with all
of them but I was like let's just okay
yeah I dated whoever and whenever until
I decided like this isn't serving me
anymore like I don't like this anymore
or obviously they also made that
decision sometimes I had one that's mom
made the decision for him so I wait wait
oh yeah oh yeah get up yeah oh
yeah dated a dude looked real great on
the outside abs BMW just tall you know
like that thing and then he was like you
have a good relationship with my mom and
I don't know no no no no that is not a
lion no I'm not the warning she ended up
calling me and breaking up with me for
him while he was silently sitting on the
phone in three-way and I didn't know he
was there what I later told her that she
needed to back the up oh my gosh
you don't normally if you tell someone's
mother to back yeah yeah yes sort of
they shouldn't yeah she broke up with me
but I was like oh no no no I'm
gonna break up with you - right right
right we're gonna get into the fight
we're gonna do I'm gonna break to you
again and then I'm gonna break up with
your son even though you already broke
up that's hilarious
yeah so yeah so I gave everybody a shot
couple shots how did you navigate before
I mean five years ago I mean the
internet dating was still poppin
yeah a little bit I was on OkCupid for
like a hot second then someone at UCB
saw me on it and like brought up in
person it was like did you eat that
yeah and I was like oh delete
yeah thank you I don't like this that's
funny also he was like giving me tips
it was weird they're like oh we're like
online dating a sport and being like
this is how you like your profile scene
more and this and that and I was like I
don't like oh that's weird
yeah that's gross I just didn't want to
do it like I don't want to do my
branding as a dater right now no one
actually is enough we have to lie yeah
did the dude who gave you tips like did
you also maybe pass on him and then in
like he was maybe like all right like
yeah you know saw your profile and like
have some nose oh maybe
yeah like oh your profiles not that
great anyway yeah yeah yeah I would have
swiped the other way yeah you don't
swipe on okay key but I don't know so
that I'm always surprised when people
like have successful relationships
through tinder that's a rom-com story
waiting to happen that's why I'm never
tendered I don't I really like it like
yeah it tenses me up like I don't I
don't like that yeah I think you should
find like internet relationships through
like social media apps I know that
that's not cool everyone's like don't
get in my dns but I'm like but I don't
know if you get a better sense of the
person you're gonna better like if I'm
just like so oh that's so frightening
like I don't want to say I don't want to
be stay well some people I don't know
what the difference is though cause like
you're still looking at this person's
like probation yeah well they're giving
you yeah on either Instagram or tender
so they're both like the same I mean
they're but I mean any at least on
tinder with people are like I'm I want
to meet people right or do you know I'm
trying to sure but it's still true
I mean that's tricky
matter what cuz you go to a bar and it's
the same scenario I mean these people
aren't what they're saying that they are
not they're always but I feel like
that's that's dating in general and yeah
is the issue with dating us no matter
the Avenue like you're gonna have its
pros and cons either way I don't want to
that's a problem I need no no my
boyfriend's got single friends I don't
know if they're like boyfriends all of
them but yeah great hi I'm looking for
there is a myers-briggs test that was
recently revealed to show that women
fall under for stress personalities and
if you know which one you are you can
navigate your stress with more ease I
took this test and Heidi took it so sure
did not which is totally fine so sure
don't worry about it
because it's not a great tell me which
one number two some of the questions are
good but some of the way that they're
worded like a comic like you stress
words and how they're being used
yes so my favorite one was I sweat a lot
in my armpits and the palms of my hands
when I am stressed it is embarrassing
yeah what's that one that's weird to you
yeah that was the thing I was like but
that's the thing I did sweat a lot but I
don't find it embarrassing cuz I don't
give a that I sweat cuz I'm a human
body so I was like this is Miss Lee some
of these questions are miss Lee I should
just be like I sweat and that's in fact
yes but they're implying that I already
embarrassed yeah you know so it's one of
those things rumbling this is there's no
way this is super accurate so that's a
two-part question yeah I play do you
find it embarrassing when you sweat if
you sweat right yeah so my my
personality was I'm a vigilant pacer
which I don't think it's accurate
because it's basically saying that I
need to get better rest and sleep which
I sleep a lot and I get up early
and I'm ready for the day at 7 a.m.
which is rare for comedians very um but
I how do you navigate stress I usually
stuff it down until I explode which is
how I answered the test it was like a
vitality sprinter right
I'm learning I learned specifically this
year that it's not really working
because I have now I have high blood
pressure and it's affecting you know my
body mass and things like that which
also starts to make you be like well now
I'm not valued as a person right you
know so like I like to like maybe go to
a dance class and don't post it right or
like go on a walk and like just have
that be for me like do things that are
just genuinely for me yeah social media
has changed the way that we exist our
day to day lives and we feel like
there's pressure to post or yeah kind of
show what's going on so that you can
remain relevant yeah like yeah you're
right I mean that's part of it part of
the balance is not always posting
everything because what is for you and
what is for show
yeah because sometimes if you do
something for you and then you post and
it made you feel good and then you post
it and it like doesn't get enough life
right someone's like yeah no dumb yeah
then all of a sudden the thing that you
did for you to relieve your stress is
the stress it makes you feel better is
like now gone makes you feel bad yeah
yeah yeah and that's like if you're a
point where you have to relieve
something like obviously if you're not
stressed and post that and then if
someone's like you're an idiot you'd be
like whoa so are you yeah I
don't get stressed out about big things
like big dramatic things gonna happen
like in my personal relationships or job
wise but I'm kinda like okay like yeah
but like little things and maybe it's
because I'm not react to the big things
that little things will set me off
sure and I I try to do more just like
headspace calls it body scans away where
I'm just like trying to read my energy
and my physicality cuz I'll spend a lot
of time like this and yeah it's a pretty
fight I got after after hanging out with
Nicole all day your life
by her her enemy so I have a bad temper
I'm not yeah and so at first like four
years I was like oh my god like I'm a
disaster cuz I just had this temper that
I can't control but then last year I
took mushrooms for the first time and I
like took these mushrooms and I was just
like oh I was so mad that the mushroom
experience was so like stereotypical it
was just like wow I'm just wrecking
everything
Wow all right we're just really okay
were high on mushrooms cooler than like
I got mad at being on mushrooms for my
body reacting like I was on mushrooms
and I went in the shower cuz I was like
why am I so mad I'm on mushrooms I was
like oh my god there's no controlling my
temper not the most basic I was
like my temper is Who I am it's in me
there's no controlling it you gotta set
it free think of that is like it's it's
own entity and it has to live and
breathe yeah why try to like cage it in
yeah that's why I tried occasion or like
or know that I'm letting it out at the
wrong times and just like oh yeah I'm
mad at this so I'll just move on and
then what and I because that's the other
thing is like telling people like no
nothing they're not now's not a good
time like yeah yeah I'm man so I don't
want to take it out on you I'm out I'm
gonna like exercise or whatever the
yeah and also like my vibrator feels
like a great great stress reliever
sometimes I don't even realize like
that's the one key but it's sometimes
that's all you need yes let's stuff out
do it we just gotta let it sometimes I
think people should accept it like if
you up you you're gonna get a push
yeah you're gonna get poked I just want
sometimes there's just people I want to
like
[Music]
we've got some questions to answer if
you have any questions you'd answered
about you love life your work life some
that you know down the street
submit them to you welcome questions at
gmail.com are you ladies ready to answer
some questions yeah great if there is no
reason to not be trusted but still want
your privacy how do you talk to your
spouse about not going through your
phone even though they have yet to find
a shred of evidence to justify the lack
of trust there's live yeah there are so
they're saying their spouse or their
partner goes through their phone I don't
think there's just going through their
phone for no reason I'm prompted through
their own relationship that's what it
said they don't want that and they don't
want that but they don't know how to
navigate I assume it's a man who doesn't
know how to talk to his woman mm-hmm I
have a policy just for me I don't know
if this is a necessity answer it I don't
go through phones anymore yeah anymore
do you know that yeah I don't go through
them anymore I think all of our phones
have things in them that know right
great like I really do I think that like
we all do like I'm sure that there's
things that you could maybe twists or
look and so I just have a policy I don't
do I don't do I don't go through phones
anymore so what why we'll look at your
comments though how do you watch my
stories how do you navigate someone
going through your phone you don't go
through my phone I'm like no you don't
go through my phone like and then it's
like if you go through my phone and then
like now Union like I knew but you know
I'd be like yeah well then what the
you want to do you want to break up you
mad about sure I'm like yeah what do you
want to do because if you didn't like
unless you went through my phone and I'm
like clearly someone else then
it's not about the text message right
you should break up with me because or
if you if you want to break up with me
because I'm cheating on you or if you
want to work it out like
that should be the decision not the text
message but I just think that if I was
up my partner would find out
outside of a phone yeah because yeah why
are we yeah I everyone wants to be a
detective
and you could just talk to the person
that you're with yeah you're already in
a very intimate relationship
hopefully yeah and have a like have open
communication be like hey I feel like
the energy shift or I see you talking to
people that I don't know or whatever the
thing is as opposed to snooping and yeah
stuff and they're in their phone I never
had a desire to go through someone's
phone have you had people do you do
phones no I don't care I'm like I mean
well it's also like I've never been in
like such a strong relationship like a
real solid
we're both weird and being inclusive
I've never had that conversation because
I'm also just like okay I don't care I
don't know how it's gonna affect me if
you choose them and then you choose them
I guess that's like I think this is a
dude who's trying to get his wife to
stop going through his phone well for
that wife I would want to know what let
her take the phone
what let her take that she needed to go
through the phone in the first place and
that's definitely a conversation to have
regardless of the feels right yes what
what are you gonna happen
what did you see or what actions did you
glean from me that made you think you
couldn't trust me sure that's a huge way
bigger conversing right yeah please that
going through my phone right that means
there's a lack of trust yeah that's true
and that's also going back to maybe he's
leaving comments on women's that he
is that he doesn't think are bad yeah
right but she's not showing that she's
seeing these comments cuz a lot of
people assume that if there are comments
that are being or that are provocative
or questionable you got to communicate
yeah you gotta have a conversation or
it's like either I want to flirt or I
see you flirting do you want if you
could if you were to do that I'm cool
with it
just don't go further than that yeah
yeah yeah all we should munication yeah
communication bro yeah yeah how do you
know when you've outgrown your friend
have you ever felt like your friends are
not on your level anymore or insecure or
jealous of your success what do you do
oh yeah yeah that's I mean yeah I've yes
all the things well also that that feels
like a two-part question
you can outgrow your friends even if
they aren't insecure right success yeah
so yes I feel like I've outgrown friends
and yes there are also a friends who
feel whatever threatened by success yes
but also not all those friends went away
like they you know you can talk to em
all about communication yeah that's why
you're in a successful relationship I
think that it helps yeah you can talk to
people and be like hey I've noticed
saying you're you're like treating me
differently or you only ask about
industry stuff when I'm around your
whatever the case and then sometimes
they don't realize that's what they're
doing yeah oh I didn't realize or if
they don't care then that didn't they
can go away but if it's like something
that can adjust and they're willing to
change it then that they can stay they
can stick around but it's like if you
love this person and you're willing to
keep them in your life I I would think
it'd be great for both of you to be
honest and say I don't feel great when
I'm around you because of X Y & Z
because you keep bringing this up or
because you don't like these other
friends that I've started making because
of whatever job I'm doing or whatever
the thing is like let's talk about it
and either it will get better or it well
and then you have your answer and like
can phase people out if that's what
feels good yeah but you're also speaking
on a good friends level because there's
also those like not good friends coming
up through comedy you make you have so
many friends
everybody friend you know everybody yeah
and then while a yeah you're all
equally ain't yeah yeah and then I
got on TV in a big way and very set in
and my circle went because I chose it to
be that way because there were certain
people where it's like I don't feel safe
or comfortable yeah people start showing
their ass yeah yeah they do they really
do yeah yeah yeah yeah and so like
they'll tell me oh you don't belong here
anymore yes
and I'm okay with that I don't know ER
because we haven't talked about it right
yeah so if you weren't that close to me
then or if you showed a side of me that
was like not serving me yeah
you can go yeah well also it's like you
have a job to do and you have like a
your own growth to deal with and if
someone is constantly making you like oh
my god like it's that you're making my
growth difficult right that's that's the
money right there you're making my
growth difficult damn us that's the
money right you know because it's like
friendships outside of good friendships
once you kind of understand who someone
is like if someone's like a person who
maybe means well but gossips a lot
mm-hmm
then I decide I don't tell that person
personal thing right like I'm not going
to get I'm not gonna be like why
you'll be talking all the time
about a right right like you also
enjoy that gossip she has to share with
you and so deciding what you can give to
people and what you can't give to people
and what maybe they can give to you and
they can't give to you and like you know
going like this is where this friendship
is at like I trust them on like this
level I trust them on to that level and
then some other is you just don't
want to be around yeah that's that I got
a list of people I don't want to be
around yeah and like fuck'em you maybe
they wasn't even really your friends
alright let them I'm all loud again my
blood pressure goes bike I love it well
thank you Lee's another great episode of
you welcome thank you everyone for
tuning in
subscribe all that my name is
marcell argüello peace
[Music]